what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start we are going to do a
quick word from our sponsors chances are
you have been here before there is chaos
in the markets oil and stocks just when
you thought it was safe and interest
rates were Rising new threats come out
of nowhere tensions are boiling from
Asia to Europe and adaptation is key
here to safeguarding your wealth you may
not have considered gold before and it's
not spec ulation but insurance and right
now you do need some insurance Noble
gold Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster four years with
precious medals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a look at gold and
silver gold is a proven Safe Haven
shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3 o Silver American
virtue coin with its new IAS this month
if you open up your Noble gold
Investments Ira or 401K rollover you can
claim your coin today remember crisis
bruise portfolios waiver and gold
insulates secure yourself against
threats go to noblegold investments.com
now that's noblegold investments.com now
the only gold company that I trust okay
guys thank you for bearing with me as
you know I got something to say today
all I have something to say so I have
been demonetized on this platform and
many of these fake news reaction
channels pulled up a tweet of mine from
6 months ago and said that was why we
were demonetized that was why they
pulled up one outof context tweet and
said Pearl was demonetized but these
fake news reaction channels they don't
even know why we were demonetized and
I'll tell you why apparently I have
hateful speech no this is the first I've
heard of it yes and YouTube still has
refused to tell me what specifically I
said that was hateful speech but to this
day they have said you will be
demonetized with no strike no warnings
just out of the blue hate
speech so just so you guys know I am now
committed I am now committed to never
doing hateful speech again hey we do not
condone hate speech on this platform and
it's so funny it's so funny because they
they come at me and they said oh one of
one of the things we got we got flagged
for a couple reasons one was hate speech
one was harassment and one was bullying
what about all the millions of channels
that bully me daily oh oh YouTube hasn't
flagged the it's so crazy it's so crazy
the double standards here the double
standards but anyways guys I am now this
is a new Leaf for me Pearl has a new
Leaf where I am committed to no longer
doing any hateful speech none so let's
let's get to today's episode of no hate
speech Yes as you guys know everybody is
trying to cancel Matt re Matt R we
recently covered he he did a series of
jokes on his channel and the woke left
was trying to cancel him or not his
channel his Netflix special and the woke
left was trying to cancel him he said
Nana you guys are crazy and if you're
offended you can kiss my ass but I did
see Tana Mojo who is basically an LA
your typical la influencer chick that's
just like been around the industry you
know um out there sexually if you catch
my drift I I found a video of her
actually destroying Matt rif it was I
couldn't even believe it cuz I really
like Matt R but this clip was so funny
guys but I'd like to say no she did not
destroy I don't want to say any hateful
speech she she had a a joke that was
funny that's the thing I don't really
hate any but I don't here's here's a
very humbling experience that I've sorry
I guess Epiphany that I've had recently
that because so many [__] people hate
me for really no reason and it really
made me realize that like people only
hate somebody they're jealous of and
I've been I've been guilty of hating
people and when I really sat back and
thought about it it was because I was
jealous of where that person was in
their life I felt like maybe they got an
opportunity that I should have gotten
that was a really really good
well-rounded answer I'm trying to wrap
my head around do you think people who
hate Osama Bin Laden are jealous of him
yeah
wait did he say
[Laughter]
yes oh I was just dying that that was so
funny no no you know what I I think
sometimes people hate you because they
have different World Views sometimes
they do hate you because they're jealous
and sometimes they hate you because they
don't like you as a person um but I I
thought that was literally hilarious um
so the comments replying says he's not
wrong the majority of hate stems from
jealousy obviously there are exceptions
notorious NES hardly destroyed she
compared not liking a comedian to not
liking a terror that's true that's true
I actually I thought it was funny I
sorry gu I know I know I know all the
guys are going to come in and say pearl
but that's Tana em Mojo we like Matt rif
I do I'm sorry but that was funny that
was funny okay I'm trying to wrap my
head around her response holds any kind
of relevance to the conversation
pertaining this particular celebrity you
can't compare apples to oranges the joke
was funny get over it the joke was funny
and I don't agree with cancel culture
and I will say that a lot of people do
come for these comedians for no reason
but I I don't think that people that
hate you are always jealous of you and
this is coming from one of the most
hated women on the internet I think some
people just don't agree with your
worldview and some people the shoe fits
so I think a lot of the people he makes
jokes about I'm sure the Shoe Fits and
so they don't like it my generation just
is whiny with a lot of excuses when I
look at my grandfathers and
great-grandfathers generation I think of
men that did not take any [__] and came
to work and got the job done
unfortunately my generation when it
comes to women and even sometimes men
that act like women often come with a
lot of excuses and whiny Behavior no no
I was brought up in a family that my dad
always taught me that you need to work
hard I have never had a boss that would
not give me a letter of recommendation I
never had it because I was always taught
show up on time do your best look them
in the eye shake their hand and this is
where you can really stand out really I
I've always believed that those who work
hard things come to now there is a
lawsuit going on because Old Miss had a
player that wanted to take a two week
mental health break now guys as you know
I am an athlete I have been playing
Athletics my entire life when I was in
high school I would train 4 hours a day
at least once a month I would be out of
state flying to a different state to
play I played very competitive
volleyball from a young age I've
competed in the NCAA tournament um I
always did multiple sports like I am an
athlete and I don't really think unless
you're an athlete you realize how long
two weeks is two weeks is so long in
athletics you might have come up with an
entirely different play you might have
an entirely different lineup in two
weeks you cannot just take two weeks off
and expect to keep up with the rest of
the people and in college athletics it
was super normal for me to come in early
so not only would you be training two
three sometimes four hours a day to the
point where they made rules about how
much you could train um I actually I
think my college got in trouble for for
this but I would come in like an hour
early I would set up extra time just to
get in the gym because I wanted to play
and I wanted to win so bad so when I
heard this story Miss defensive tackle
to Santo rolands stated in his latest
court filings against Rebels head coach
lay kein that he was intentionally
intentionally treated him differently
than white players and provided two
allegations as examples Roland who is
Black alleged evidence of disperate
treatment of white and black football
players in a court filing submitted
through his lawyer Carol Edwards roads
per an exclusive via AJ Perez of front
office Sports this particular filing has
launched a series of rebuttal to kin's
motions to dismiss Roland's lawsuits
against the head coach in University for
failure to provide equal protection
racial and sexual discrimination among
multiple allegations per ESPN's Heather
D as far as examples the lawsuit stated
that a white male kicker for the
football team tested positive for drugs
and Coach kein gave him a break from the
team but was not kicked off the team by
coach kein in
2022 the kicker is still with ol Miss
per the lawsuit now I will say again as
someone that was involved in college
sports I don't know what drugs that that
guy tested positive for but I I don't
think that's uncommon amongst athletes I
just I'm just being honest guys the
filing also stated that kein gave
another white player a break from the
team after his father fell ill and later
passed away this player is still with
the rebels Roland's original lawsuit her
DCH claimed that kein took adverse
action versus Roland on the account of
race for requesting and taking a mental
health break but not taking adverse
action against white student athlet when
I was in college there was a girl on my
volleyball team who had a similar
attitude where she would blame things on
her race when the truth of the matter
was her lack of playing time had nothing
to do with her race but rather it had
everything to do with her inab ability
to show up to things and she would
always be out of shape we would always
every summer we would have to come in
and there was fitness test that we had
to pass she never passed I remember guys
we had to do a burpee Circle this was
hell this was hell on Earth and you
would have to do you would basically
have to do there was like five girls in
a circle and you would have to do five
burpees and then when you're on the
fifth Burpee the next girl would go and
then you would get to 10 burpees you
would stop and you had to get 100 burp
bures within um like 10 burpees per
person but uh total 100 burpees a person
it was it was a lie to this day I hate
doing burpees guys and you would have to
achieve that goal within a certain
amount of time and if you didn't get it
you would have to restart and this chick
was always on my team all do you even
understand guys she was always and so we
would have to re imagine redoing a
hundred burpees because one girl came in
out of shape one girl and and they would
divide it because there was maybe like
girls um on a squad and maybe they
divided it into five I don't really
remember how they divide like how many
girls were in each group but go you know
you know what that's like and and it
would be the same thing the jump rope
she would and so you know sometimes she
would say things that implied that she
was treated a certain way because she
was very athletic and she would come in
and you would think she would get
playing time cuz she was a really good
recruit but she wouldn't she would show
up late to things and and so when she
didn't get playing
time you know or was treated a certain
way it had nothing to do with her race
but it had everything to
do with her inability to show up on time
so this is what this sounds like I am
the CEO I know all the excuses now look
I was not I was not I didn't like school
I always was super in Sports school was
not my thing so when it came to
school I don't know if all of my
teachers would have the best things to
say about me sorry guys um but you know
and so you start to know based on the
person what is a real excuse and you you
start to realize over time what people
actually want to be there and what
people just want to give excuses and
typically when there are situations
where okay if one girl got more leeway
for the same situation with a different
girl it might be because girl one showed
up on time to everything else and this
was just a one-time occurrence where
girl two this was a regular a normal
thing kein motions to dismiss the
lawsuit for the following reasons okay
kein is entitled to qualified immunity
with respect to plantant equal
protection claim and a direct equal
protection claim cannot lie against an
individual the university is a immune
from Ada liability under the 11th
Amendment and kefin cannot be
individually liable for Ada violations
kin is not liable for intentional
infliction of emotional distress the
court should decline supplemental
jurisdiction over plaintiff state laws
claims in support of their motion
defendants rely upon the pledging and
papers filed in this manner including
their accompanying brief in support okay
basically this guy's suing let's just
okay and H guys I just have no sympathy
Athletics is so simple it is so simple
if you produce you will be on the court
and in all honesty you have even if you
don't start off playing when I was in
high school I was at this club I was at
this club okay and I I had the least
playing time I was a benchwarmer on the
third team I wasn't even on the B team I
was on the C team and over a matter of
four years I worked really hard and I
made it to the a team and anything
outside of that it's just excuses I
cannot take this but anyways there is a
audio recording of their racist
interaction apparently so I want to hear
it let's pull it up if you would have
come here when you kept getting messages
the head coach wants to talk to you and
you saying I'm not ready to talk to him
what wasn't well what world do you live
in I don't see why you got to be
disrespectful honestly get out of here
go go you're off the team you're done
see
see because I see you go go and guess
what we can kick you off the team so go
read your rights about mental health we
can kick you off the team for not
showing up when the head coach has to
meet with you and you don't show up for
weeks okay we can remove you from the
team it's called being a p it's called
hiding behind and not showing up to work
okay and and do you see that so he says
you didn't show up for weeks you know
when it's one thing to come to a coach
and the thing is I have had such
positive experiences with coaches
overall most coaches if you come in and
say you can't just blame it on your
mental health you can't you can't do
that but if you say I have had a family
member that passed away can I have two
weeks off many will give it to you it
but what you can't do is just say oh oh
I I have mental health I'm not going to
come for two weeks you can't do that and
I don't know what world you guys live in
where you think you can just not show up
College athletics is so competitive and
I was in female college athletic there
is way more of a demand to go in male
College athletics so if you don't want a
spot on a team especially at Old Miss a
division one school there are 10 men
that are waiting to take that spot this
guy's on scholarship and he just decides
not to show up for two weeks oh no you
leave No SI you get no sympathy from me
Stephen America 317 says dude leaves for
2 weeks won't talk to anyone and then
comes back up to record their
conversation and tries to sue tell me
this ain't a setup um Ma you look says
mental health bro you go to college for
free and play
ball no honestly and and that's the
thing being a student athlete is so fun
it it is so fun you get to I mean you
have to do the school stuff whatever but
I mean half of the athletes will get an
easy degree and just play Not Your
Country Club kein doesn't sound out of
line kids don't want to be held
accountable for anything these days yes
our generation is soft he is so soft
okay so that is my take on and I'm not
bullying but I think I think you need I
think you need to get thicker skin okay
I met jyon very briefly on a uh stream
with sneo um and it's been interesting
to see Gideon's development over the
last couple of years jyon was one of the
biggest prank YouTubers I have ever seen
I have cried laughing watching some of
Jon's videos for example he went to a
WNBA game and just
slept it's kind of weird to watch
another man
sleep he just slept next to the court um
and he he was just known for being like
the ultimate troll he was so funny um
but jyon I've recently seen him come
back to Christianity so he's coming back
I think he was raised a Christian and
recently he's sort of been going back
and forth deciding what he wants to do
with his life I've watched jyon go back
and forth sort of debating with some of
the influencers saying that he is a
Christian and Christianity is important
to him believe in God cuz he got you
subscribers no I believe in God because
of just what he's done in my life got
your subscribers not even that no it's
just I was in a very dark place like I
did not know where I was going to go
like I was stuck I was I was like neck
deep in mud and I got pulled out so
recently he made a video talking about
why he deleted all of his videos and he
is never coming back to prank YouTube
let's pull it up and I won't ever be the
way I was anymore so if you won't cut me
off from you then I need to cut myself
off from you so that's why I deleted all
my videos I don't want to be the St
Block in your way no more I don't want
to be the reason why you keep on living
in sin I don't want to be a hindrance
from keeping you from the kingdom of God
no longer so that's why all my content
is gone and that's why I'll never come
back and wow I know we made a lot of
good memories and I know a lot of my
content wasn't quote unquote that bad
I'm going just get rid of all of it it's
all gone I'll never be seen again
because I love you guys and J Hest come
out and said that he needs to follow God
he wants to remove his videos because
the sexual innuendos um the provoking
people and the sexual immorality okay so
there's been a mixed reaction to this
some people are reacting and saying this
is amazing and great other people are
reacting and saying no no you don't have
to delete the video so here is a video
of
zurka um talking about why jyon should
not delete the videos this is called
John zerker calls out judon and other
Christian YouTubers remember the dude I
was telling you about earlier that was
texting me oh yeah who's yeah yeah don't
don't spoil it yet don't don't don't
spoil it yet but we'll see what he said
I have a message to Christians around
the world most of you are
ineffective losers get the out of our
way well you just got to stop swearing
and get married and you boring ruined
everything get out out of our way no you
know why I don't care why I don't care
that I swear I'm not supposed to curse
why I don't care is cuz I'm washed in
the blood in the spirit in the fruits of
God [__] so I use my swear words I
don't mean to
cuss but I mean to cuss because it gets
me more views people like when I'm angry
so I cuss hey yo [__] have you accepted
Christ so I'm stop it there uh so I'm
going to give you guys the context of
why he's saying what he's saying um I
don't want to go too much in text and
stuff like that but the gist of it was
he hit me up and was basically saying
like um uh becoming a better Christian
does not mean the end of your comedy you
can make playful videos it's the relief
you bring to millions of souls suffering
in the devil Matrix do not extinguish
the light God gave you find a way to
integrate it and I was like did you
watch the the entire video zurka and he
was like I watched the one where you
said you deleting I was like then you
know why I had to remove all of it and
he was like is it because of the guy's
job and stuff and I was like I can't
cause people to sin any longer I was
like watch the video and you'll see why
I had to delete everything and he was
like if I believed in this style I would
have done it myself but the truth is if
I don't cuss and swear I get no views
meaning I would not I would have missed
out on converting my whole audience to
Christ followers the compromise in life
is sin that's been paid for the blood of
Christ your comedy doesn't need to die
you are being radicalized you can reach
Millions if you use your Talons who do
not swear and are married and are good
useless Christians I'm also going to go
through the comments section before I
give my take another why says when that
money
starts sees that he don't make it as
easy in the real world he'll be back
sevenly said I respect this a lot
because he truly just wants to be a good
in fluence and spread positive message
Christianity is his Outlet to do it
cheese for me says dude right now I
think he made his bag and decided he has
enough guessing he'll be back when it
runs out so I have mixed feelings on
this okay I have mixed feelings this is
just my gut okay not bullying not
bullying anyone just giving my opinion I
think what he said was correct with the
sexual
inuendos okay I I could see the the corn
jokes being too far the [__] uality
but I also think that he has a gift I
think that jyon is probably the most
gifted um YouTuber I have seen in a long
time and I've also seen him do pranks
that attack wokeness I've seen him make
fun of this woke culture um I can't I
can't I can't I can't remember exactly
but I remember he did um a joke
about like getting adopted into a white
f it was so it was so funny I can't I
wish I could remember exactly what it
was it scrubbed off the internet but so
do I think this is genuine I do yes do I
think he has good intentions I do I just
have a feeling he's getting involved in
one of those woke churches and the
reason I I think that is because
typically in the woke churches they're
very concerned with how you say things
they're very concerned with being
politically correct being good on paper
and one of the first things that the
churches kind of do is they control spee
then you get these female Pastors in
there preachers I don't know I'd have to
see what church he's going to just a gut
feeling about it do I think he can
convert so I have to think about zura's
point because zurka was saying
essentially you have to swear in order
to convert as many people I think
there's still a way to be funny um and
still live according to Christian and C
Christ sorry I'm Catholic so it's my gut
going according to Christian values and
I think sometimes when you get things
that are a little too py it becomes woke
um but overall I think it's a good thing
I I don't think he needed to delete the
videos I think there's sometimes he went
too far but I think overall they were a
net positive I also think that he can
still do pranks and that sort of thing
in a different way so it'll be
interesting to see how his content
evolves in the future I think it's too
soon to really say if it's genuine or
not I think we're going to see soon in
the next couple years does he stay away
or does he come back and I think that's
why a lot of times I think a lot of
times people don't trust influencers
converting because they always do it
after they get the money after they get
the fame and it's almost like a write of
Passage to get famous and then convert
so I I I understand why the comment
section takes it like that where people
just suddenly find God after they get
famous um not saying that's what he's
doing I'm not bullying anybody that's I
think why people will take it that way
okay so the next story I have is Elon
Musk so Elon Musk is quite the guy he
bought Twitter because he is motivated
to have a truly free speech Network so
someone that has been demonetized on
YouTube or this hateful speech this is
something that I'm very passionate about
I really hope that Twitter can compete
with YouTube someday because it is very
frustrating as a content creator to be
constantly having to censor myself with
vague guidelines that don't tell us what
we did wrong so essentially YouTube can
just come in and say every day oh that's
hate speech that's hate speech that's
hate speech just because they feel like
it everyone's been trying to call Elon
Musk anti-semitic that that has been the
new thing Elon Musk wants free speech so
therefore he anti-semitic and someone
who has dealt with that I I understand
where he's coming from so he silenced an
entire room full of people by telling
them to [__] off like okay imagine guys
you can't tell me God wouldn't want him
to tell people to [__] off I know I know
I'm sorry I'm a Catholic but I'm an
Irish Catholic all right look it some
sometimes there's something about Brave
about telling people to go f themselves
so basically all advertisers have been
pulling out of Twitter to be a free
speech platform basically they've been
trying to make Twitter go broke because
it will not go woke let's pull up the
footage you don't want them to advertise
no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
with money go [__]
yourself
but go [__]
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob that was
hilarious I did you see how the half the
room's laughing the other half is like
doesn't know what to do I think this is
amazing I think that Elon Musk has a
daughter that he sent to an elite
private school that became woke started
to hate her billionaire father and I
think this pissed him off so I think
he's just on a mission to make Twitter a
truly or X now a truly free speech
platform and I really think that Twitter
is one of the few places that are going
to be able to do it Twitter Rumble
really are the only true Free Speech
platform so smok and Soldier MC says
trying to Blackmail the richest guy on
the planet LOL pretty much the response
I would expect Mason says why will they
want to Blackmail it just because he's
the richest man on earth hey you
blackmailers go get a job um this brown
geek Elon is the real MVP what a legend
they've been running smear campaigns
against Elon for such a long time and he
simply had enough mainstream media and
advertisers who blackmail Elon need to
hear this message loud and clear if Elon
could make Twitter a free speech
platform that pays similar to how
YouTube pays I think you will see a
complete change in society I think that
will be the end of wokeness but we will
not see the end of wokeness until we can
have honest and open conversations about
anything I am so tired of especially
women and feminine men coming in and
saying you can't say that you can't do
that when really I just think there's
something beautiful and that's honestly
guys when I started my channel that's
what I love having open and honest
conversations about hot button issues
and not coming in with this agenda but
you get into YouTube and you just
realize everyone has an audience they're
catering to everyone has an agenda
there's so few people that actually want
to have a truly free speech platform and
actually want to have open honest
conversations that reflect what we see
in society so I want to tell you guys a
story a couple of years ago I believed
that you should never hit a woman I
thought that hitting a woman was wrong
and that really what would a woman need
to do to like to deserve to be hit I was
una aware of just how violent women are
where I grew up it was not normal to
have women hit men that wasn't something
I really saw ever but the more I got
into media the more I had conversations
with men and women the more I realize
that behind closed doors women
absolutely beat the [__] out of their
husbands they they do it often
boyfriends and I couldn't believe how
many men had been hit by women and so I
started to see the types of punches that
these women would throw and I thought to
myself if you want to hit like a man
then expect to get hit like a man I have
zero sympathy so here is a video of a
woman beating up her husband as soon as
he got home from
work
what on
Earth okay so this guy comes home from a
long tough day at work just to have his
wife beat him now imagine if it was the
other way around how would Society react
that woman should be in prison women
often want want the freedom to do
whatever they want without the price or
the responsibility that comes with it
women want the freedom to beat up their
husband without being held accountable
by the law or through self-defense they
want men to just sit there and take it
and I say lady if you want to hit like a
dude if you want to behave like a dude
then expect the consequences that dudes
face and dudes that hit their wives tend
to go to jail or tend to get beat up by
another guy that defends the woman I
have even seen videos of men beating
women or playing pretend beating women
in public and women beating men in
public and overwhelmingly nobody helps
other men step in to defend the woman
immediately men cannot hit women and
they are not abusing women like the
feminist say that they are so my message
to women is if you want to hit like a
man then expect to get hit like a man
and don't cry to me about it when he hit
you when you hit first this was another
red pill that I realized I interviewed
over a thousand women on my show and so
many times they would complain about an
ex-boyfriend that was abusive or toxic
and when I got to the bottom of it I
found out that she was actually beating
him imagine having the audacity to get
mad at your boyfriend for defending
himself often times she would hit him or
she would refuse to leave him alone or
leave his property and many times the
men were just trying to push the woman
off of him I'll give you an example of
how women Lie by Omission one woman said
that he shoved me down the stairs now
when I got to the bottom of the story
what really happened was she was
trespassing she went into his house and
refused to leave now should he have
shoved her down the stairs no but from
what I uncovered in the story all he was
trying to do is get her out of the house
he was trying to get her to leave what
this woman left out was that she was
trespassing no you don't have the right
to be there just because you're dating
the same way the men don't have the
right right to just be in our Apartments
because we are dating um and so many
times you guys want the freedom to do
whatever you want without the
responsibility so I tweeted this I said
this is why I say if women want to throw
punches like dudes they can expect to
get hit like dudes Bill Corbit says
whenever you create a culture of women
who feel empowered to assault any man
you create a subculture of men who will
physically defend themselves men are
evolving at a high rate the governor
says I remember this video and a lot of
people said the infamous he must have
done something to make her act that way
and my message to the women is no no no
there is nothing that a man can do to
make you act a certain way you are
either violent or you are not violent
you are either capable of hitting a guy
or you are not capable of hitting a guy
and when I first heard that women were
hitting men I thought it was just like a
play hit I thought it was just like a
play oh and then I started seeing this
stuff chica this is insane this is crazy
no he did not make you crazy you are
just crazy you either have it in you or
you don't have it in you and if you have
it in you then you need help you need
help go get help the same way the men go
get help nobody can bring something out
of you that you don't have inside of you
so if you guys want to hit your
boyfriends my my message to you is
expect to get hit back the last comment
says this year is the result of
stripping a man's Natural Instinct for
him in order to protect women but not
giving all the attention to women when
they need to be reminded that they live
in a physical world and men can be
dangerous far too long this has been
stripped and therefore women like this
forget who they are tampering with just
like a child so that is all for today's
episode every episode we read the top
comment below so if you guys have a
comment you want red next episode
comment below and like your favorite
comment all right Aaron levit 6820 said
how bizarre is it that men have always
been the ones to approach or ask out
women that they're interested in and yet
feminists and basically now the law well
shouted no that is not how we want
courtship to work anymore how dare a man
ask a woman out and the single ladies
are left like this yes women want to say
that men are creepy that approach them
and then get mad when we are not
approached unfortunately all of these
crazy blue-haired feminists have ruined
it for everybody as you guys know we can
be kicked off of this platform at any
time and um yesterday we did lose a
Clips channel so make sure you sign up
for email list we are launching a new
site soon and I want you guys to be the
first to be notified and make sure you
get our merch to help support the
channel we have whale merch we have
women shouldn't be online merch we have
women shouldn't vote merch merch so make
sure you go get that today I'll talk to
you next
time